salut aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un
sujet qui m'intéresse beaucoup je veux
vous parler devant une place parce que
one pluzz vous savez sortent des
produits régulièrement on a eu le web
pluzz 10 pro en début d'année on n'a pas
eu de voix de plus 10 on a une gamme qui
hélas historiquement je vous en fait
très très rapidement ou une place et est
un smartphone plus un modèle non lui
c'est un smartphone et un modèle t il ya
eu un smartphone avec le modèle pro plus
le modèle et modalités modalités pro
ainsi que de la neige est arrivée la
gamme nord du nord dit l'un d'entre eux
enfin bref y'en a beaucoup énormément il
y en a beaucoup et pas la question à se
poser aujourd'hui est ce que one pleut
c'est toujours une marque qui compte ce
qui est toujours une marque qu'il faut
venir acheter c'est toujours une marque
intéressante et ça c'est une vraie
question parce que wang place ils ont
été restructurés hydre rechange et leurs
stratégies plus orienté vers un milieu
de gamme avec beaucoup de produits dont
ce nouveau produit qui vient de sortir
ban a là il vient d'être annoncée donc
c'est pour ça que ce monsieur ce serait
l'occasion de venir se poser cette
question de venir regarder si ce one
plus lourde était déjà intéressant puis
surtout est ce que ça vaut le coup
aujourd'hui d'acheter du wan place en
2022 est-ce que c'est intéressant parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de difficultés parce
que c'est pas des produits qu'on va
trouver en magasin en valais commandé
sur internet on s'est produit pour un
public averti donc voilà alors il ya des
produits il ya des bugs j'allais one
piece nord de bugs ya plein de trucs
mais c'est vraiment une question je
trouve extrêmement passionnante essayer
de comprendre comment marche cette
marque est ce qu'il faut venir se
positionner à ce qu'il faut venir
lâcheté quelle difficulté où ils n'ont
quoi comment est ce que on peut leur
faire confiance
et puis surtout et qui continue avec des
produits de qualité aujourd'hui en 2022
c'est son regard tout autour d'yves à
montbard où
e
[Musique]
c'est un bordel absolue j'ai récupéré à
des trucs de tous les côtés là je rentre
tout juste de milan où j'étais parti
avec huawei pour aller découvrir des
nouveaux produits et j'en ai un peu de
tous les côtés voyez c'est un peu le
manque ce j'ai même ce moniteur là qui
est en train de me demander tu es donc
si vous avez des recommandations pour
des moniteurs couleur pour venir à
bosser parce qu'elle shinobi ben voila
vous me le dites parce que ça ça
m'intéresse que témoin dans les
commentaires
[Applaudissements]
ok alors on se parle de ça parce que ça
c'est un truc intéressant wyplosz nord
d'alors attendait le smartphone je l'ait
emmené les ici c'est vrai que one place
est une marque qui coule one place et
est la marque des mecs qui s'y
connaissent un poste ailleurs quand vous
veniez shirwan place c'est que vous
désirez attentats qui tuent connaît
telle marque ou telle la nan nan moi
j'ai une vraie marque je vais te l'a
montré ses ouailles place c'est un truc
de connaisseurs et ça circulait un peu
en dessous des autres en dessous des
rameurs en attendant tu connais pas one
place à temps avait expliqué sauf qu'ils
ont des difficultés il avait un ou deux
produits par an et on arrive un moment
où démarque avec un ou deux produits par
web plus vivre d'autant plus qu'avec
l'explosion des autres marques avec
l'arrivée de tous les autres acteurs
chinois avec notamment des chiens au mit
qui ont pété le marché avec des produits
tous les côtés bref c'est devenu
extrêmement compliqué pour une marque
extrêmement je veux dire allez flagship
qui leur pointu à les tarifs cool de
continuer d'exister mon réseau structuré
et ils ont dit cette gamme nord de cette
commande est intéressant parce que là
vous avez le one + noord 2t ça devient
compliqué le nom si chez eux un web plus
norde de thé parce qu'il ya eu les one +
norns le premier il ya une loi de plus
nord 2 on l'a déjà vu et sa déclinaison
tu es donc c'est en gros de la demie
générations avant le web +93 donc c'est
du one + norns 2t c'est pas du wan plus
north ce qui encore un peu moins cher
voyez comment c'est un peu un peu
compliqué en suivant toutes les marques
la foule on se sent un peu d'eau est ce
que cette part qui a continué de cool
quoi c'est vraiment l'idée parce que on
est moins dans l'idée du produit un peu
flagship là on est à combien attendez
j'ai le tarif là on a une version 1 828
qui coûte 4 129 euros c'est quand même
un peu un petit budget et 12 250 6 529
euros donc allé à quasiment 500 balles
est ce que ça vaut le coup de venir
acheter un smartphone comme ça tout en
sachant que ce smartphone n'est pas
disponible dans les magasins on peut pas
venir le voir le prendre le touch elle
sentir le renifler comme ça on se remet
donc piste à il est bon soit plus tôt
non pas du tout
lui il faut le voir sur le web on le
regarde au travers de vidéos comme vous
le voyez comme ça donc est-ce que c'est
intéressant et c'est toute la
problématique d'ailleurs ils ont chez
chéreau en place aujourd'hui c'est de se
dire est ce qu'on arrive à bien
communiquer sur nos produits est ce
qu'on les voit bien et aussi tout ça
c'est vraiment un très très gros
problème mais moins déjà ce que je vais
vous montrer je vous parle un peu du
pour nous parce qu'on se parle de lame a
effectivement je veux qu'on fasse un
petit focus sur celui là sera loin de
plus normes 2t ouvrant le nom il faut le
tenir il ya plusieurs choses à savoir
chez one pleuvent déjà wyplosz ils sont
rapprochés de pau donc aujourd'hui toute
la r&d et mise en commun avec au pot ou
pau c'est un énorme géant qui fait des
produits ils sont super cools déjà ça
c'est une gaze de qualité des soins que
leur groupe cbdca clé dans le groupe
dans lequel il ya wyplosz il ya
forcément au pot il y a vivo qui est de
danse voilà il y en a plusieurs c'est
une espèce de gros conglomérats
groupement de constructeurs de
smartphones je pense pas que mais je
suis très loin de tout connaître là
dedans donc déjà on sait combien des
gages de qualité avec un développement
r&d avec au fond ça s'écoute deuxième
truc a vraiment fait la force de vente
plus en plus du tarif avec des grosses
pattes parce que ce qu'ils aient moins
de place et qui m'ont très ému ce qui
montrait les spectres et à regarder moi
je fais ça je fais ça je fais ça je le
fais pour quel prix je suis moins cher
que les autres tous ces gens - aoste est
énorme sauf que là on est plus dans le
même segment ont déployé du flagship
tueur le flagship c'est le smartphone
très haut de gamme et j'étais en slip et
un peu le truc donc là on n'est plus là
dedans là on est dans l'idée du un
milieu de gamme parce que là où se font
les volumes de vente c'est dans le
milieu de gamme c'est pas dans le très
haut de gamme kia que quand vous voyez
par exemple lors apple s'est un peu
différent parce que il bosse pas dû trop
des produits milieu de gamme mise à part
l'iphone est ce ça peu différents corps
mec là où tous les autres font leur
beurre c'est dans le milieu de gamme
samsung par exemple c'est pas les s
22h22 plus 16-22 ultras qui vont prendre
le plus là où ils ont de la valeur oui
effectivement mais là où ils font le
volume est là où il faut le business
c'est sur la gama'a 53 73 et compagnie
donc là c'est là où on fait le beurre
donc il faut venir se positionner en
face et quand vous êtes one love et vous
n'êtes pas en magasin c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'il faut venir
convaincre les gens il faut venir
convaincre les revendeurs les retailer
de vous faire de la place dans les
magasins mais déjà il faut commencer en
vente sur le web donc et son rôle soit
d'ailleurs si ce produit vous intéresse
je vous mets le lien dans la description
à l'ivoire ou moins de place donc ils
ont effectivement le hardware qui est
très bon et qui marche bien alors je
vous fais très très rapidement j'ai
appris par coeur on n'est pas chez toi
comme on est chez mediatek la c1 d'hymen
city 305 j'ai alors je vous passe la
fiche technique parce que c'est pas trop
tôt nous intéressait basque 4005 mais
bon on s'en fout un peu le truc qui nous
intéresse réellement c'est regarder
c'est là dedans c'est lui là c'est le
blog de charges alors parce que c'est un
très bon bloc de charges ça c'est du 80
watts et ça c'est pas mal et je vous dis
à peu près 500 euros donc là
effectivement il ya de la techno et
s'écoulent entre techno qui est
intéressant ici c'est que vous avez
alors la ram c'est la hype et d'aider à
4x ça convient dans le milieu de gamme
vous inquiétez pas stockage c'est de
l'usb 3.0 au delà du quota un peu techno
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on a un
smartphone qui sera réactif en termes de
vitesse d'écriture et de lecture pour
tout ce qui va être dit ming ça va être
cool on est sur un prof milieu de gamme
avec de la 5g donc pour venir jouer à
des jeux pour du gaming voyaient ils ont
fait un truc où il faut dissoudre pas de
vous donc ça c'est intéressant également
le truc que j'aime bien et si c'est
effectivement ce module photo ça me fait
penser un peu un petit côté je trouve au
nord 50 plutôt qu'ils ont gardé et qu'on
trouve dans l'idée de one love c'est ça
la voyez c'est ce petit slide la sas et
les seuls à faire ça donc ça c'est un
truc génial donc si vous aimez vous y
allez goûter si vous n'avez pas goûté
vous allez peut-être aimé sonnerie
vibreur en intermédiaire est tout en
haut vous mettez en mode donc vous
choisissez vraiment si vous l'êtes
dérange ou pas déranger un instant t
donc ça c'est cool là hop là mon capteur
d'empreintes digitales qu'est ce qu'il
fait je les plantes et 2 octobre à la
capture des empreintes digitales ça
marche c'est très réactif et c'est cool
autre point qui est vachement important
aussi c'est toute l'expérience software
parce qu'on est sur oxygen ouest et ça
c'est un sujet qui intéresse pas
pourquoi parce que one pluzz comme ils
viennent mutualisé ou ski et r&d
recherche et développement avec au pot
ils viennent un peu sopo si fier au pot
si faut purifier aux policiers m ils
viennent un peu comme au pourquoi
pourquoi parce que forcément il faut
gagner un peu sur les coûts et si on
peut mutualiser ça coûte moins cher et
c'est intéressant alors ils ont fait un
truc quoi une pelouse qui est bien c'est
qu'ils ont amené à seul blade
spécialiste de la photo au niveau du
finepix cinq pros ça leur a permis
d'avoir tout super intéressante idée je
trouvais que le au pot 10pro été moins
bon contrairement aux peaux neuf pros
qui était bien meilleur en photo castle
blade enfin bref c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui le poc est vachement
important c'est de l'expérience logiciel
c'est un truc adore les gens qui sont
fans de one place c'est oxygène ou est
ce parce qu oxygène os c'est quand même
vachement cool et si vous aimez toute
cette expérience là et bien oxygène
boisson peut pas parce qu'on peut pas
passer à côté le menu est bien le menu
est simple le menu est clair le menu est
lisible on peut venir personnalisé pas
mal de choses c'est très très bien fichu
c'est très très bien pensé et souvent
les gens se disent ouais mais est ce
qu'ils vont pas où elles peuvent faire
comme due aux pommettes du colosse à
terme je pense qu'on va y arriver je
pense qu'à terme on aura un col hors os
sera très très proche d'un oxygène os et
que ça parle toujours oxygène noël ce
sera extrêmement proche d'ailleurs il
faut savoir que en chine ça pas oxygène
au sc hydrogène os je crois pas qu'ils
aient switch et je crois que je pense
qu'ils me colle aux récents que c'est
quand même vraiment hydrogène os qui est
resté et qui fait la force pour moi de
ce truc là donc après bon c'est
l'android 12 ça marche autre chose qui
est intéressante chez one place et les
mises à jour soft et les mises à jour de
sécurité qui continue à perdurer dans le
temps je sais pas si nous on dit la soie
combien de temps je n'ai pas noté autre
truc qu'il faut bien voir alors bon on
va pas aller se faire un test poussé
parce que je sors tout vous en parler
parce qu on est sur un smartphone milieu
de gamme comme beaucoup de smartphones
milieu gamme je vous montrerai quand
même quelques photos tout à l'heure ils
ont fait un choix qui est intéressant
vous avez 1 50 méga pixels c'est
lit-et-mixe 766 qu'un super capteur sony
qui marche très bien on regardera donc
quelques instants on a aussi un ultra
grand temps de 8 mégapixels on s'en fout
un peu macro 2 mégapixels on s'en fout
un peu et une celle-ci 30 2 mégapixels
pourquoi pas c'est intéressant et ça
reste très correct très honnêtement je
pense que le point fort de ce smartphone
scellier milk 766 sans capteur principal
qui peut être vraiment intéressante
alors je vous montre quelques photos
prises avec ce smartphone voyez on a
changé de vêtements on a changé d'heure
c'est la nuit bon voilà on est quand
même là je vous montre quelques photos
qui ont été faites avec ce smartphone
parce qu'un seul capteur principal a
fait le job regardez ça c'est une photo
son capteur principal il ya quelques
petits défauts qu'on va venir repérer on
voit là quand aulas sur le hdr il a un
peu galéré au niveau du ciel c'est un
peu tout kramo c'est un peu le point un
truc un peu relou sinon dans l'ensemble
ça fera le taf on peut passer sur
l'ultra grand temps mais vous le
recommande pas au niveau du hdr c'est
pas terrible les détails sont pas ouf
voilà on y passe sur un smartphone de
foule et pas sur un photophone deux
fournées sur un foie de ici hockey et on
va jusqu'au x 10 nous on va guère plus
loin c'est moi qui ai galérais je sais
pas ce que j'ai fait j'ai eu je pense
que c'est ma vie j'ai vraiment fait de
la merde chez les des photos de scènes
filmées je n'ai pas une dawn est méchant
que ça vient de brassens en face à
vannes du smartphone je pense que soit
il a pas reconnus soit j'ai fait trop
vite j'ai bougé ça n'a pas fait là sur
un contre jour ils arrivent à s'en
sortir c'est pas dingue mais malgré tout
il s'en sort on va quand même les nuages
on calcule hd atteint plutôt pas trop
mal bossé ça fonctionne c'est à peu près
correct c'est pas top top attention
c'est pas les plus belles photos mais ça
fera le taf là j'ai essayé de vraiment
faire le focus ici sans le bâtiment il
ya côté un peu blanchâtre au niveau du
traitement ce n'est pas très très
bourrin mais bon voilà j'ai vraiment
poussé dans ses retranchements et on
voit que c'est pas un smartphone qui
fait pour ça très honnêtement vous voyez
s'il assure un métro on va bien le
soleil sur un capteur principal si vous
êtes bien explosé de la lumière ça fera
le job c'est très classique celle
optique ça marchera bien mais dès qu'on
vient trop jouer et se rapprocher ça
marche pas trop comptable luminosité
toujours qu'une petite source le métro
ça ira la voyez c'est plutôt cool alors
comme on n'a pas de femme optique comme
beaucoup de smartphones d'entrée de
gamme de prix bien la nuit si vous le
prenez à la main ça va tout de suite
être pas terrible vous dire le poser le
calais et là vous seriez tous ceux qui
sont assez sympa vous voyez qu'on serait
plus qu ils font plutôt cool il est
correct en photo alors 5 aux autour de
500 euros on trouvera mieux en photo que
ce one + norde de thé mais dans
l'ensemble sans capteur principal le
rendu est honnête donc voyez en fait là
ils nous sortent un smartphone dans le
milieu de gamme aux alentours des 5 sens
mal qui tient vraiment la route par
rapport à ce cas la concurrence on a un
chargeur qui est là 80 watts rapide on a
toujours un câble qui est hyper stylé
c'est le plus beau cadeau du marché on
se le dire le câble rouge de one + moi
je suis hyper fan et c'est très très
cool voilà on a un truc qui tient bien
on a un smart phone call girl vote dalle
cdu amoled ils n'ont pas lu ni les îles
les ide les îles eysines et ils n'ont
pas lésiné taux de rafraîchissement de
90 ans ça se tient aussi ses cours avec
il existe du 120 hertz mais très
honnêtement 90120 c'est pas ça qui va me
gêner n'y a pas de soucis privilégié de
la recharge rapide pour tout vous dire
je veux absolument du 120 heures ça
c'est quand même ce qui sera beaucoup
plus malin ici voilà on en a une fiche
technique qui tient la route pour autant
est ce que le consommateur mais si je
vais aller dessus alors wifi six élèves
c'est tout rond point de croix c'est
très cool et continue à faire du one
love c'est à dire qu'ils fussent
technique solide qui tient la route on
peut leur faire confiance mais est ce
que pour autant je vais aller moi
acheter du vin de place chez pas et vous
savez tout est hyper dur et cite une
chaleur incroyable le truc hyper dur
pour eux c'est qu'en fait ils sont pas
un magasin je permets de bois mais là où
ils sont forts ski bosses qui bosse
quand même vachement bien derrière ils
sont arrivés chez des opérateurs là vous
les avez chez orange choix qu'ils vont
arriver je suis oui alors ils sont
fâchés à cette armée est sûr que ça
arrivera vers trouver en ligne chez
leclerc boulanger fnac darty amazon donc
comme on sait que la plupart des gens en
france en fait ils achètent leurs
smartphones par leur opérateur et bien
en fait vous allez pouvoir les retrouver
chez vos opérations permettra de les
démultiplier de la retrouver parce que
très honnêtement il vous le dit franco
de billets les yeux dans les yeux les
smartphones de one poisson cool j'ai
trouvé qu'ils ont été un peu moins bons
en photo avec le one + 10 pro ça m'a un
peu frustré mais pour autant le produit
est beau le produit bien fait
l'expérience logiciel est là donc
aujourd'hui leur manque quelques petits
trucs qu'il leur manque que ça pousse un
petit peu derrière il leur manque que la
grande distribution les prennent et les
mettre en rayon en magasin on se rende
compte mais moi sept matchs continuent à
y croire je trouve qu'elle continue à
être cool à être sexy ça devient très
très dur d'autant plus qu'à plein
d'acteurs qui a qui continuent à arriver
via laughing qui va sortir son
smartphone qui peut aussi changer un peu
l'histoire ça peut être une marque on
m'a semblé qu'il est vachement
intéressant tout ça dépend des anciens
nouvelles pleuvent donc vivons une
vision extrêmement intéressante garder
sur leur but c'est assez mignon mais
c'est pas le truc qui fait le plus
qu'ali comme ça mais après je trouvais
jolie leurs petits bugs garder son
mignon non je n'ai pas encore essayé hd
découvre d'abord est ce classique mais
après sur des bottes comme ça on
s'attend pas à voir un truc qui va vous
surprendre et qui va être dit foudre de
guerre donc en fait cette marque pour
moi aujourd'hui elle continue à être là
elle continue d'exister c'est une marque
qui continuent à être sérieusement que
si vous voulez acheter ou une plaque
pour être une place mais je pense
qu'elle est très peu connu du grand
public je pense que pour eux il leur
faut tout refaire il leur faut
reconstruire travail et ils ont une base
d'image cayla auprès de technophiles qui
connaissait et aimait bien mais un vrai
gros boulot derrière pour reprendre tout
ce travail et positionner la marque
wyplosz mais pour autant c'est le game
nerd peut-être ça qui va venir sauver
wang pl us plutôt que 10 pro ou des 10
et compagnie c'est beau c'est dans le
milieu de gamme venir se positionner
face à des acteurs comme des chiens au
mit qui n'hésite pas à bombarder alors
il y aura beaucoup moins smartphones que
schumi c'est une évidence parce que je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
se battre avec les mêmes armes mais la
marque continue à être coulés et si vous
êtes technophiles on peut y aller dit le
moderato qui m'intéressent vachement
avare en commentaires je pense que
beaucoup de gens qui ont acheté wang
losc qui regarde moi une place c'est
parce qu'un ami à eux leur a dit regarde
wyplosz est une marque intéressante je
connais une marque que tu ne connais pas
et tu verras elle est meilleure les
autres je pense que c'est ce que se
disent les mecs parce qu'il ya un côté
un peu comment dit on est recommandé par
quelqu'un et on se sent faisant partie
d'un groupe parce qu'on est recommandé
comtois sont en place et je pense que
c'est vraiment le truc qui fait la
puissance de la marque aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle est un peu d'un côté un peu
connaisseurs plutôt que de se dire c'est
la marque très grand public tout le
monde à venir acheter et je pense qu'ils
vont avoir du mal à rentrer dans un truc
très grand public tout le monde vient
acheter mais petit à petit les
mayonnaises va continuer à reprendre moi
j'y crois si vous voulez acheter une
place je pouvais y aller c'est sérieux
c'est beau le moins de plus disent
proches le moins bien dessus il est cool
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
ce que vous avez du world press que vous
avez déjà qu'ils deviennent plus est ce
que vous avez été déçu par one pleuvent
est ce qu'au contraire vous êtes
toujours fidèle à la marque dites le moi
aux commentaires c'est intéressant je
reste un homme et croyez moi les gens ne
veulent plus ils vont aller jeter un
oeil il vaut regarder donc si vous
écrivez soyez sûrs quoi ne plaise à vous
lire on dit ce que vous avez à dire vous
embrasse à très bientôt et dites moi ça
vous intéresse convient de décortiquer
un peu les marques comme ça qu'on
regarde qu'on parle de produits c'est un
peu notre façon d'en parler parce que
sauf quand les produits sont toujours un
peu les mêmes renvoyer même s'il ya
certainement des atouts d'autres
différends là on va regarder soi peu
différemment je trouve ça cool dit le
moment commentaires on en reparle très
vite de wyplay c'est pas notre marque
d'ici là prenez soin de vous je vous
embrasse et beaucoup d'amour surtout de
l'amour ciao
[Musique]